It is very difficult to it on the same
thing.
It's like a person wants to stop
smoking,
right?
They're addicted to smoking and he's not
so hard to stop one,
two,
three days.
But most people will relapse after two
or three days.
The same thing with,
with uh,
with diets and food for once these,
these changes that'll cure these
condition responses.
Number one are long lasting.
So you are going to be constantly
inhibiting these pre potent,
uh,
nice to actually want to it.
Now Imagine Your Day,
24 hours.
I sort of sorts of the managing my day
24 hours in the morning and go run
exercise.
I'm all all wired up so I have perfect
control.
Nothing bad has happened to me.
But then I basic alley loose,
loose my key on,
I have to make these huge line and then
the secretary insults me and I have to
say,
no,
I'm not going to get.
So you start to get frustrated.
I'm frustrated and frustrated and angry
and angry and your ability to then
regulate this urge to eat the food
starts to be on their mind.
So as we get frustrated,
as we get stressed,
our ability to exert control gets
diminished.
So you're going to die then this is one,
one of the reasons is not the only
reason,
and I'll,
I'll come back to it in a second.
The ability to exert control,
to control our emotions and our
behaviors gets eroded when we're
stressed,
when we're tired or actually when we're
full deprived and that's why people
become irritable.
This is actually,
it's a response where your,
your brain,
your body sensing that you are in a
state of deprivation and under a state
of the premade Bayesian,
your main full state changes to go and
want to do that behavior that will get
you out of that state.
So you have again that balance of an
intense drive to get out of that very
unpleasant state and on the other one
your cognition and says,
I want to lose weight,
I want to lose weight and there is a
point that you do lose.
You lose this battle and so you give in
and you get a stressor comes up.
The flight has been canceled.
I've been dealing with all of these,
these psych had a bad day on my flight
on top of everything gets canceled.
And at that moment you lose the ability
to control.
So that's one of the things I need to,
exactly the same thing with drugs or
weed smoking behavior.
A person he's doing fine and all of a
sudden their spouse says,
you know,
I want the divorce when they have been
stopped smoking and then they relapse.
Something very,
very stressful.
They lose that ability.
There are all other things that,
that are um,
being,
um,
shown by animal stories that may also
being very,
very provocative.
And again,
this is at the research level in
animals.
It hasn't been shown in humans,
but in my view,
the moment that I started to see results
like that in animals,
I want to question,
is this happening in humans?
There's been a series of stories now by
Dr Hobble,
uh,
for many years.
And I,
I,
when I read these I said,
wow,
where he takes rods on key,
gives them a diet high in sure we'll,
we'll eat the societies a lot of sugar.
Well,
he takes these little ruts and gives
them high amounts of sugar and then he
takes these animals and gives them,
I draw that we call an opiate antagonist
now.
Why do you say an opiate?
The Taiwanese and not being a townie.
Some medication that when you give to a
rat only when you give it to a rod that
has been repeatedly exposed to opiates
like I'm caroline.
Morphine,
oxycontin,
repeated exposure only when it's
repeated,
you gave that you trigger,
I withdraw like a heroin withdraw.
The animus satish shatters.
It's gets to shake and a,
it's very,
very unpleasant for the animal.
When a kid these these opiate antagonist
into an animal that has been exposed to
high content of sugar,
he triggers an opiate withdraw.
This is incredibly unpleasant.
Now,
one of the things that we haven't
studied in humans is could there be
something similar that they're eas are
we draw out just like it's been shown in
animals or Kurian when a person is a
stops in a diet and then they basically
are courting the intake of sugar which
liberates endogenous opiates,
so no longer those endogenous opiates
are being liberated and your creating a
mile state of withdraw that he's not of
course so powerful that you recognize
it,
but that may be creating this state of
dysphoria and discomfort.
This is artifactually factually,
which is what happens when you put
someone on on withdrawal.
Maya withdrawal from opiates.
It's not like they're going to start
shaking,
but there's a sense of discomfort.
It's just you're not feeling well on
your Stinger like like that and it's
very unpleasant.
And so the,
the extent to which a similar process,
for example,
maybe happening is something that should
be investigated that could also,
if proven correct,
help to understand why so very difficult
to go into a diet.
And we'll also,
if it's again,
a document that in humans,
because this is documented in animals,
could provide a strategist to help so
on,
so that they don't have these very,
these very disagreeable state of
discomfort.